critique is so limiting and emotionally
draining I hope you find something to
explain what's happening which one's
better one
oh it's to better worse no different no
different I am quite curious to know II
think I think sober hasn't been good for
him appears was in the full bloom of
alcoholism ear exactly never should have
quit drinking no originality no courage
my opinion I can't save you
mesmeric and you just took them you have
no family or friends I can make you rich
it's brilliant
demand has people ready to kill I mean
good as an artist I'm thankful Diesel's
no we have everyone the artist used
blood to create the reddish blocked you
ever notice anything about this page you
look at it long enough it moves
as I research these I'm starting to
think there's my disgust for the world
of money who spent decades in a
psychiatric hospital for the criminally
insane
there is some sort of power
some spirits
it connected to his art
something truly goddamn strange is going
on this is the slaughterhouse
are you aware the DS asked that all is
art be destroyed
[Applause]
okay we did it
I can save you
[Music]
[Music]
people thought she was thought an
exhibit we're trending on Instagram it's
a major hit
you